Speaker 1: Let's go next to James in Cambridge.
Speaker 2: Hey, David, can you hear me all right?
Speaker 1: I can hear you fine, James.
Speaker 2: Hi. First I was wondering,
you said something in a show I think
about a week ago about that. It's
it's a myth that the United States ever promised
Gorbachev or anyone that Naito wouldn't expand
eastwards. And I was just wondering where
you had read that because because I've just
read some things that are contradictory.
So I was just kind of curious about that.
Speaker 1: I don't remember the specific source,
but my understanding of the story was that it was
verbally offered as a concession at one point
in negotiations, but that it was subsequently
removed at the direction of U.S. and, I believe,
German dignitaries. And it was never codified or
signed anywhere and actually made an agreement.
Speaker 2: OK, OK, I just want a clarification
on that, because I had just seen some transcripts
from George Washington University that described,
as you said, that it was verbally promised.
And my second question which is more to do
with Trump is why is it that Trump is often
portrayed as a populist? Because first of all,
the bulk of his support actually came from higher
income people? Yes. And secondly, his policies
were incredibly beneficial to the rich.
For my estimation, he's one of the most
elitist presidents in American history.
Speaker 1: So your conclusion is correct.
He's one of the most elitist. I don't I don't know
that it's accurate to say the bulk of his support
came from high income people. Is it possible? What
you meant is high income people supported him more
than Hillary? Is that maybe that's what you meant?
Speaker 2: Yeah, yeah. I to reword what I said. On
average, in 2016 and 2020, the average income
of his supporters was higher than the average
income of either of the Democratic nominees.
Speaker 1: OK, now remember, if average means
mean, that could not be a super useful metric.
But let's not even concern ourselves with that,
because your main point is a good one, which
is about policy. Yes, Trump has been was an
incredibly elitist president. The tax reform plan
disproportionately benefited the very wealthy
and the things he promised to do for middle
income people, lower income people. He didn't do,
and I don't know why he was called the populist.
I mean, there's two perspectives on that. One is
that he's a right wing populist. Others would say
right wing populism doesn't actually exist. He
just used populist rhetoric, but he's not actually
a populist. It becomes more of a semantic debate.
But the conclusions the right one. Trump was one
of the most pro elitist presidents we've had.
Speaker 2: Yeah, he also destroyed a lot of labor
regulations that that, especially in COVID, were
really disastrous. Yeah, I would actually say that
people like AOC and Bernie Sanders are more are
legitimately populist in terms of policy substance
and anybody like Trump or Josh or Josh Hawley.
Speaker 1: I agree with you 100 percent.
Speaker 2: So, yeah, thanks for. Thanks
for taking my call, David. Thank you.
Speaker 1: And then the left a little
prematurely there, but that's OK. Let's go next.
Where where are we going next? How about how about
Jason in Atlanta? Jason, you're on the air.
Speaker 4: Hi, David, I'm calling. I was
wondering, you have in the past mentioned support
for a shorter workweek. First of all, how many
hours do you think would be ideal? I know Keynes
predicted by 2030 we'd have a 15 hour workweek.
Speaker 1: Yeah, the the prediction from Keynes
has not is an old prediction. He predicted that
as technology increase productivity, people
would basically have mostly time for leisure.
And you know, it's an old prediction that turned
out not not to be right. And there's a lot of
different reasons why I have not devoted a lot
of time to the number of hours that I think is
the I think it's different in different industries
and different types of jobs. In particular, there
are jobs where you quite literally are selling
your labor an hour at a time. And so if you
reduce the number of hours in order to keep the
same compensation, your hourly rate needs to go
up. And that's very different for someone working
at McDonald's versus someone who is like a lawyer
or a therapist that is compensated hourly but
has more control over their wage. So for me,
it's less about that. I don't have the answers to
that, but I've been very supportive of the idea
that the bulk of our work can easily be condensed
into four days in a lot of information type jobs.
I want to be really clear about that. And at
the show, we condense production of our five
weekly shows into four days. So number of hours,
I don't know, you know, different industries,
different answers. But I think much of how
work is organized is not super efficient
in terms of providing the most leisure time.
Speaker 4: OK, yeah, thank you, and you kind of
answered my next question was going to be which
was how we would make up for the lost income,
because if most people are working hourly,
if they get their hours cut, they would
Speaker 2: be making less money
Speaker 1: right with salaried workers.
If you become more inspired and more efficient by
knowing that your workweek is shorter and you kind
of get the same amount of work done, you could say
that takes care of itself. There are some who say,
Well, we don't really need as much efficiency as
we actually get. It would be OK if we were not
quite as if it. There's really a lot of different
opinions about that. But for the hourly worker
who you know, if you go to someone who makes
15 bucks an hour working nine to five Monday
through Friday and you a great news, you
now only work Monday through Thursday.
If you don't make any other change, you've
taken 20 percent of their income, right? Yeah.
I don't have an answer. Yeah, thanks, Jason,
from Atlanta, very, very important question.